there is a magic in the air at 5 a.m
habits don't restrict freedom they
create it you know it's often the people
who have the worst habits that have the
least amount of freedom
this may be the most important reason
each and every one of you should start
working out
and it has nothing to do with living
longer wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the
five habits that people learn
too late in life enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one join the 5 a.m club with robin
sharma
there is a reason many of the great
women and men of the world the great
history makers the great poets the great
philosophers the great
movement makers rose before the sun
there is
a magic in the air at 5 a.m and that's
why the 5am club is so transformational
because
it's the time of greatest quietude and i
believe
tranquility is the new luxury on our
planet it is the
time of intimate creativity because
you've just been rested your brain is
fresh there's
there's latest there's there's very
recent cutting edge science coming out
now when you sleep your brain actually
has a mechanism
to wash itself when you wake up in the
morning your willpower
is strongest when you wake up in the
morning you've got a full well of mental
focus and we know that focus
in our world is even more valuable than
intelligence and i could go on and on on
the benefits
i mean you get up at 5am you've got the
world to yourself
there's no crowds you can think you can
plan
you can care for yourself in a world
where so many people
are so depleted and so the fi it the 5
a.m club really is a game changer and
then
it's not just get up at 5am and you know
scratch your stomach or
stare up at the ceiling or look at your
phone or look at especially not
i believe you can play with your phone
or change the world you don't get to do
both yeah
and so uh it the 5am club method is
based on the 20 20 20 formula i'm happy
to get into it but that
what it is that's the revolutionizer and
and it started from
my experience with working with many
billionaires i i've coached many of the
most successful financiers and
titans of industry for for over two
decades
and one of the things i would run them
through is the way you begin your day
sets up the way you live your day
and so the 20 20 20 formula that the
book is based upon is
pretty simple i go into great detail in
the book but
essentially it's from 5 to 5 20 the
first pocket is
move and i'm a fanatic about
neuroscience and
why do you get up and move because
you're going to release serotonin which
is going to make you feel better you're
going to release dopamine which is the
pleasure and inspirational
neurotransmitter
you're going to release norepinephrine
which will boost your focus
you'll promote neurogenesis marie you
can actually grow new brain cells
you'll increase your metabolic rate so
the way you beg
the way you feel when you first wake up
is not the way you're going to feel at 5
20.
second pocket of the 20 20 20 formula 20
minutes from 5
20 to 5 40 that's on reflection so a lot
of us are busy but what's the point of
being
busy if you're doing the wrong things
the the billionaires the great creatives
the people of great impact the people
who live beautiful lives are very
intentional
they're very deliberate they're very
conscious so for 20 minutes
you write in a journal you can visualize
you can pray
you can meditate you can simply
contemplate how you're going to live
your day what you want to stand for
during the day for example and then the
final pocket of the 20 20 20 formula is
all about grow
and that's where you you just read from
a biography or a business book or a
philosophy book or a
watch marietv well especially watching
tv
yeah of course that's the game changer
isn't it and so
that's 20 minutes of growing because i
think we're most alive
when we are growing yes and um i believe
the leader who learns the most wins
so that's in a nutshell the 20 20 20
formula habit number two
create freedom with james clear this is
one of the most common
uh i guess criticisms or complaints that
people ask me about with habits is like
well you know i don't want to be robotic
right like what about like spontaneity
what about the you know freedom and
doing what i want you know i don't want
to like pigeonhole myself in this
lifestyle
but uh it's this false dichotomy because
habits don't restrict freedom they
create it
you know it's often the people who have
the worst habits that have the least
amount of freedom it's the people who
have terrible financial habits that are
always wondering like where the next
dollar will come from or it's the people
who have
poor learning habits that are always one
like feeling like they're behind the
curve
um or people who have poor fitness
habits that are always struggling to
find energy
but on the other hand if you have your
habits dialed in
if you like you know have your your
fitness habits figured out if you've got
your finances handled
then you actually have way more freedom
than you did before now you actually
have the space
to you have the energy to do what you
want you have the strength to do what
you want you have the financial ability
to spend time in
areas that you want and all of that
comes
from getting your habits handled so it's
it's uh
it is a little counterintuitive this
idea that like discipline equals freedom
or habits do not restrict freedom they
create it but
it's it's true that if you can handle
that stuff if the fundamentals of life
are
dialed in then you've got space for
spontaneity and creativity and freedom
and all the other stuff
habit number three take care of your
body and mind with tom
bilyeu they're very concrete habits
that you can use that i have used once
you get your mind in the right place
once you believe that it can happen
this is what i did i worked out why
because it helped me gain control of my
mind
one it was micro credibility with myself
every day i said i was going to do
something i did it
two when you're suffering and you're
willing to fight through it you tell
yourself a story
that you're willing to pay the price to
become what you want to become and also
and this may be the most important
reason each and every one of you should
start working out and it has nothing
to do with living longer because we
could get hit by a meteorite who knows
so i'm not even worried about that but i
am worried about this
when you watch your body transform you
get the loudest signal from your
subconscious that you can change
that you can change anything you want
that you can change your bicep your
tricep your quad whatever it is you want
something that you literally could not
do the day before you can do
today and your mind sees
that that's true your mind
sees that something you couldn't pick up
yesterday you can pick up today
and it begins to ask itself well if
that's possible then what else is
possible
now for me finding my center was also a
very important thing so
i work out first the next thing i do
without fail is meditate
i do adjust breathe meditation where i'm
simply trying to calm my mind
then i do what i call thinkitating
during meditating
i get into an alpha wave state brain
pattern which enhances creativity and
unique connections
i'm not worried about whether i'll ever
think a unique thought i am simply
interested in the unique connections
that i will make
that no one else before me or after me
will ever make because their
circumstances are different than mine
and that to me is what makes each of us
a beautiful snowflake
is we're all going to make connections
that other people might not make
and so during thinking i take advantage
of a problem i'm trying to solve
i smash it together with my alpha wave
state and i see what comes out of it
i read i read obsessively because i
believe in one simple math equation
ideas in equal ideas out and then i keep
a list of the most important things i'm
trying to accomplish
if you're trying to become something you
need to know what that something is
what's up everybody i want to talk about
the amazing book by evan carmichael
built
to serve i want to read you guys a
section this is from
um a part under the heading of your pain
is your strength
this is the fundamental mind shift that
most people never make but is required
for
success the pain that you went through
that you're trying to forget
it's your strength it's the way through
it's your answer
that pain is how you become the tree
you've experienced the pain
grow from it and are stronger now and
are able to help others who need
the support so there it is your pain
is the very thing that's going to get
you through it's kind of like what ryan
holliday says the obstacle
is the way all right guys check it out
build to serve by evan carmichael who
can teach a master class on how to be a
badass and be good to people
dude is rad check out his book a lot of
amazing stuff in there
habit number four use the five-second
rule with mel robbins
if you're in a situation where
you should do something and the excuses
roll in
you only have five seconds before the
excuses when yeah that's it
and it has to do with how your brain is
designed
and so i started seeing this five second
window
everywhere everywhere you walk
into a networking meeting and the
five-second window is right there
because you look around and you see all
these people you should talk to and you
feel yourself freeze
54321 and you can start walking
if you're trying to sell something the
five second window's always there
because you either have a phone you need
to pick up and make a phone call or you
have a person you need to talk to
but instead of doing it that five second
window's right there and the excuses
roll in and then you're not doing it
yep and so we talk ourselves out of it
right after five seconds like why not to
do it all
and then it's even more sophisticated
than that is which which is what i
discovered
and what's more sophisticated about it
is that
you have two modes to your brain you
have the prefrontal cortex
which is the mode of your brain it's the
front part of your brain
that does all your strategic planning
your decision making your
not all your decision making that's
wrong it does your intentional decision
making
conscious decision making it's what
you're using when you're acting with
courage it's what you're using when
you are learning anything new if you've
ever taken a standardized test
when you walk out of a standardized test
what do you have you have a freaking
headache because you've been using this
part of your brain
that's the one part the other part is
the interior part of your brain which
automates everything it's where
self-doubt is it's where habits are it's
where
automated decision-making is it's where
every negative
[ __ ] [ __ ] that we do it's stuck
right here
so what the five second rule is actually
doing on a very sophisticated level
is it's switching off this part and
awakening
the part that gives you control and so
the problem with our excuses
if you want to get into the brain
science is that if you
start to think and you start to think i
feel tired or i don't want to or i'm too
stressed out or now's not the right time
that becomes automatic and it gets
encoded right here so part of the
problem with our excuses is that when
you stop and think and hesitate
you trigger your brain to automatically
talk you out of it
that's the problem it's not the excuses
it's that your brain
has done it over and over and now it
takes over right so i invented the
world's
um most powerful cheat code for the
brain
one night when i was drunk sitting in my
living room watching television
and habit number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is structure your days with jordan
peterson you should use a calendar to
structure your days
because if you know what you're doing
tomorrow it decreases your anxiety
substantially because you need that kind
of structure
you need a pathway you need to know you
need to have a map and you need to know
where you're located on the map and you
need to know how you're moving forward
and that
gives you hope because you're moving
towards goals that you regard as
worthwhile and it stops you from being
anxious because you're not entirely
directionless and lost
and so learning how to manage your time
is useful and you can start with a
calendar you can start with simple
things like you can put in
well when you're likely to go to bed and
when you're likely to get up
and and regulating that's useful that
should be relatively
ritualistically consistent now i've got
a special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated
and then you actually create an action
plan for what you're going to do
you increase it from 35 to 91
chance of you actually following through
and when you share your plan publicly
that jumps to 95 chance of following
through so i want that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you most people are crazy busy but don't
get anything done
if you feel like you're crazy busy like
you barely have any enough time for
yourself that you get to the end of the
week
and you know you've been you've been
hauling ass all week long you've been
you've been busting your face in you've
been working and working and working
super busy but then you look back and
you say what did i actually do this week
if that's you then this message is for
you you're busy
but you're not focused and shifting your
life begins with shifting your
priorities
so i used to pride myself on responding
to email
asap quickly like you send me an email
30 seconds to 60 seconds later you would
get my response
i prided myself on like that's good
service that's what you should do as an
entrepreneur right like people
communicating with you
you want to send it back to them quickly
i hated having to wait and wait and wait
on people so i didn't want to be that
for others
so i had all my notifications turned on
and as soon as an email came in
ding came in boom response go what made
it worse was people would then get my
response they tended to be on the
computer at the same time
and then they write back right away and
say wow you're really quick
like thank you so much and that fed that
fed the identity that fed
the ego and i am very fast exactly
right there's proof that this thing
works
the problem was i wasn't getting
important done
i was working on something and then the
notification came in and i stopped what
i was working on to go answer this email
feel great about myself that little hit
and then come back to my project like
what was i working on
and it it takes time to start getting
back into the flow of work in that thing
and then another email comes in
and so i ended up being busy i was
working all day long
all day long right like lunch at the
desk breakfast at the desk dinner at the
desk all day long
right washroom back to the desk there
was no breaks
all day long straight through when i get
to the end of the day end of the week
like what did i do this week
i don't know but i answered a lot of
emails
because i didn't have focus i didn't
have priorities and when i realized that
after that happened enough times i
realized wow
this is i'm never gonna get close to my
goals like just doing this all i'm doing
is reacting to other people's goals
when somebody shoots me an email that's
what they want they're demanding my time
and i'm giving it to them freely because
i have no defense around my time because
i have no respect or on time i'm just
letting it bleed out
there's no time for me to work on what i
want and so i'm not going to make any
progress on the things that i want
if you want to make progress on the
things that you want you have to carve
out time for the things that you want
that's how it works and you got to put
gates and blockades and barriers around
and say this is my focused time
and nobody's allowed in now worst case
emergencies
family awesome but there aren't that
many actual emergencies
you have to be willing to let the small
balls drop
to go for the big goals in your life you
have to pick you can't do both
really well you have to pick what do you
want to be great at do you want to be
great at getting every little small
thing done
and then never do the big thing or do
you want to be great at getting the big
things done
and risk losing some of the small things
because by
chasing down the big things you're going
to lose some small things
i'm going to give a three-step process
follow along and let's change your life
step number one decide on your top three
goals right now what are your top three
goals most important things to you right
now what are your priorities
the three big things that have to happen
for you what are they get clear
get specific if you don't know what they
are that's why you're not chasing
anything big down
if you even thought about it then then
that's the problem you're stuck in these
small
projects for life what are your three
big goals for your business and your
life right now
step two is map your actions to your
ambitions whatever you say you want to
do will not happen unless it's in your
calendar you need to map
your actions what you're doing to your
ambitions what you say you want
what you're doing has to lead to what
you say you want out of life
you can say you want all this stuff but
if you're not doing the work you're
never going to get there
and most people live there you say you
want this but you're doing something
totally different over here
because it's on your calendar you
haven't prioritized it so now it's time
to pull out your calendar
and map your actions to your ambitions
for those three goals you need to put
time in your calendar
every week to make progress on them you
have to
your calendar is never going to
miraculously open up there's only going
to be more people who have demands to
your time and want you to react to their
life
to their emergencies to their goals
instead of you fulfilling your own
so pull out your calendar and show
yourself where in the week
you're going to block off the time to
map your actions to your ambitions
and make time to make those three goals
of yours happen
so step three is block the time and take
small losses for big wins
physically put into your calendar this
block of time on monday afternoon i'm
spending on xyz
and i am okay with losing some small
losses
i will not be reachable i might lose a
deal there might be some
burn down happening that i can't take
charge of i'm going to disappoint
somebody i'm going to let somebody down
not with not with intentionally
not on purpose but it's gonna happen
and you're not gonna kick yourself for
doing it because what you're gonna make
you're gonna make that time count
those two hours four hours six hours
eight hours however long you're spending
working on your goals
you're going to make that time count
you're sacrificing all these small wins
that you love going after
to make this time count so use that as
pressure
not to feel guilty about yourself for
not doing those little small wins
and being linked getting back to people
but in saying i am working on something
that's going to change my
life and because of these people who are
dependent on me for everything else and
i'm pushing that off i better make this
time count
use that pressure to drive you forwards
instead of backwards
[Music]
if you want to know the 10 skills that
are hard to learn but will pay
off forever check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there one of the things you would want
to
be sure to do is
whether you like it or not